- We always like to finish
up with something cool
trending on social media,
this is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
A Chicago woman is using
her love of crocheting
and her passion for her community
to make a real statement.
She launched her own
handmade clothing brand
called T'KOR Couture,
and she calls it the intersection
of fashion and the Civil Rights movement.
We have her on the line watching
on NBC Chicago right now.
What's up, Dinah?
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
I'm so excited to be here.
- Oh my God, I'm so excited as well.
You're getting real
traction on social media.
So what inspired your line?
- So I taught myself to crochet
when I was 12 years old.
Just started off with
a basic hat, scarves.
And a few years passed,
and I really wanted to
stretch my crochet abilities,
and so, I happened to stumble
onto this Facebook page
that was just full of other Black woman
crocheting real clothing.
And so, it just really opened up my mind
to the possibilities.
And so, this was really reinforced
when I went to the University of Chicago.
I decided to major in sociology,
and I just learned so
much about my heritage
and how it related to fashion.
Like how the Black
Panther Party used dress
as a tool to push its political agenda.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, I really just feel
very much inspired by that
and want to use that in my own crocheting
as I continue to uplift the
stories from communities
that often go unheard.
- Man, it's so cool.
I just, I don't believe in art
unless it has messaging behind
it, whatever the message is.
And I think it's so cool
how your line works.
It's just, it's an
incredibly inspiring thing.
So talk us through some of your work.
- Yeah, so one of the projects
that I'm really proud of
was inspired by the book
"The Colored Girls" by Ntozake Shange.
And this is basically a story
about a lot of different woman of color
each representing a color,
red, blue, green, et cetera.
And so I took these characters
and their stories and made
an outfit for each of them.
I also love my fluffy bucket hats.
I made these just because I was tired
of having hats that didn't
necessarily fit my head.
And so, I love to wear protective
styles and my big afro,
and I just wanted a hat that
was as versatile as my hair.
- Yeah.
- And finally one of the
people that truly inspire me
is artist Jean-Michel Basquiat.
He is known for his crown symbol,
which he placed on Black icons
to redefine the notion of race and power.
And so, I use the crown
motif in my own work
in an effort to continue
to uplift the stories
coming from communities of color.
- You are incredibly cool, ma'am.
Oh my gosh.
Like that whole ass look too is so rad.
I thank you so much, Dinah.
You're incredibly gifted.
Keep inspiring us.
I'm liking your posts
right now, all right.
- [Dinah] Thank you.
- And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you.
So, they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
I appreciate that.
- Oh my gosh.
You're so cool, Dinah.
I can't wait to see what you do next.
Incredible.
Thank you so much.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Shania Twain, Kylen, Anali,
Niteri, Alana, and Chris Powell.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.